[Music]
you just play and let the chips fall
where they may
and and you know save your money
enjoy yourself
but don't you don't try to
because when you start doing that
it's like i'm gonna play in this game in
this preseason game but i'm i'm not i'm
gonna play not to get hurt well who's
the first person to get hurt
that guy
and and that's the way
not everybody but the mentality some
some of the guys would have was i'm
gonna play this this amount of time or
i'm gonna play this way
in this game
and you can't play that way
and you can't your mindset i don't think
you you can be successful
because before you know it it's over and
you go well i thought i was going to
play years but
i didn't even make the roster
and i i saw that happen so many times it
sounds like a broader life lesson she
just all in every day and then
kind of let what happens happen
yeah
yeah you know and i
the
what was so cool about the game of
football and
the
the teammates
was all different backgrounds race
size
speed there was it was just a
discrepancy but
we came together as one and that was the
beauty of it
when you won a an unbelievable game that
you've won on last play
celebrating with your teammates there's
nothing like it i can't describe to you
what that feeling is to see
the guys look at me like
man we did it we did it and the wii is
an important part of that that phrase
and they're like throwing a touchdown
past the lambeau field there's no
substitute
for that we
that united feeling that and losing a
tough game together man crying i cried
in many a days
after a tough loss but i cried with my
teammates
and because it mattered
and um
not every guy
played that way or with that passion or
i i think
when it was over for him however many
years it was
how
how much or how little
they didn't appreciate it
yeah
and uh i coached high school football
for two years when i retired
didn't make any money didn't want any
money and enjoyed the hell out of it
and i thought i was it was kind of a
favor to the head coach
to to be his offense coordinator
but i it ended up being a blessing
because i really enjoyed it
but i would tell those kids all the time
you got to enjoy the moment i said first
of all you're young when i was your age
i couldn't wait to be 21 or
move on to the next level
and while i was fortunate enough that i
played long enough the nfl that
time sort of stopped if that makes sense
yeah along the way that i could kind of
stop and smell the roses
you know the first seven five seven
eight years man it was boss the wall
just going blowing and going and next
thing i know it's like it seemed like it
took forever but before you knew it
it's like you know when you turn 30 the
next birthday is 50 you're 53. yeah and
the next birthday was 53 like damn
where'd all the 23 years in between go
just you know you know so
i was fortunate enough that i played
long enough that i could kind of stop
and say you know enjoy this
enjoy this moment
no matter how fun or
or disappointing it is enjoy this moment
because there'll be a time when it
too quickly it'll be gone and i saw so
many guys not that it was
here and gone
just like them and never got to to
appreciate it
so tomorrow you can see part two of that
conversation with brett favre it's going
to be on fox nation part one that's
already online subscribe to the fox news
youtube channel to catch our nightly
opens stories that are changing the
world and changing your life from tucker
carlson tonight